Okay.
We've been talking for years about how we
might be able to in some way expand the offerings
of the David Pakman show to appeal.
Also to reach more people who don't speak
English or maybe don't speak English well
enough to really watch like political discussion
shows like this one.
Uh, what way might we be able to do the sort
of obvious idea in terms of another language
would be Spanish.
I'm from Argentina.
My first language is Spanish.
I learned English as a second language when
I moved here.
And Spanish would be the sort of natural way
to go in my mind.
Number one because it's the only other language
I speak fluently.
Uh, and also because it seems like it would
be a good target population in the United
States given that we mostly deal with American
politics because of the increased importance
of the Spanish speaking of voter, uh, in influencing
elections in the United States.
Now, from a practical standpoint, we're pretty
busy just doing the show in English that we
do and the bonus show for members in English
that we do and live streams in English that
I do.
So the idea of me doing an entire additional
show in Spanish seems to sort of stretch the
limits of what is possible given that the
days 24 hours long, and I also need some time
to sleep, but I was contacted by two graduate
students who developed a system that can take
our captions.
We now a caption, all of our content on Youtube,
in English.
Obviously they've developed a system that
can take those captions, dub them into other
languages, including Spanish, and then sync
them to the original videos that we are doing
now.
It's not perfect, but it's very interesting.
Here's a clip, just 45 seconds from one of
the stories I did on Monday where the captions
were taken, turned into a Spanish narration
and then placed over the video from that day.
Take a look.
[inaudible] Hey [inaudible] my Blanca Donald
Trump, sue frio [inaudible] the Washington
Post strawberry, two eights [inaudible] mass
locals.
I see Chris how ago The Washington Post Escribio
over those two.
It's the Racista.
They don't all Trump El Domingo, [inaudible]
[inaudible], Washington [inaudible].
You know the don't stimulate ACR equally.
The Washington Post [inaudible] when we went
to the bathroom [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] come in.
They compare it to your enemies not perspective
at Cornell, Washington Post.
Okay.
So anybody who speaks Spanish will realize
it is not perfect.
But we started, uh, the David Pakman show
in English to reach as many people as possible
and to try to influence politics and policy
to the extent that we are able in a way that
we think is for the betterment of the country.
What we could do is start a second youtube
channel.
The David Pakman show Spanish on a daily basis.
All of the content we do on the regular David
Pakman show channel in English could be dubbed
and put on the David Pakman show Spanish channel.
It would be the same stories.
It would be the same content dubbed to Spanish.
The downsides are it's not perfect.
Like I said, obviously it would be better
for me to just do the entire show again in
Spanish, but it's just not possible.
It's not practical.
Another downside as we'd be starting from
scratch with an audience.
Most of our current audience is an English
speaking audience.
Uh, and even uh, the, even though Spanish
is a language that is often taken by people
in high school, College, whatever, the majority
of our audience is not going to switch over
or be interested in the David Pakman show
in Spanish.
So we're sort of like starting from scratch
trying to build a new audience.
The other downside is this is not free, right?
There's a cost to getting the dubbed videos
to managing an additional youtube channel.
The upsides are similar or related to the
downsides.
It is a completely new market.
On the one hand, we're starting from scratch
trying to build an audience in Spanish, but
it is a completely new market.
I believe it's a valuable service to people
who live in the United States but don't speak
English well enough to consume political content
in English.
They could become engaged.
The other upside is, I don't know of any other
American progressive media show that is doing
something like this and sometimes being the
first to do something can be a really great
advantage and provide something that is extraordinarily
valuable.
So we could get this going relatively quickly
if we decide to.
I want to hear from you.
What do you think about this?
Is it good enough to warrant doing?
Should we be waiting for some better technology?
Should we just look at translating the captions
to Spanish?
Uh, seems less engaging for sure.
Um, this would be a channel with Spanish language
titles, Spanish descriptions, it would all
be in Spanish.
So I think it's interesting.
I want to hear from you.
Contact me by email.
This is the best way.
Now when I really want to hear serious commentary
from the audience, use the contact form@davidpacman.com
to get in touch and tell me what you think
about this idea.